Hello and welcome the fire of learning.
Did you know that domesticated foxes exist,
which may be kept as pets?
Well,
with some of the cool and exotic animals people are keeping as pets these days
perhaps is not that surprising to you.
However,
these are not simply normal foxes.
The Russian domesticated Red Fox is a Fox intentionally bred to be friendly to
humans and it's story provides a fascinating insight into how to breeding or
more technically artificials election works.
It all began almost 60 years ago in the Soviet Union with Russian scientist
Dimitri belly of.
During this time period,
the Soviet Union held onto a moderately anti scientific ideology known as
Lysenko Wisdom,
which stood in contrast to belly gabs work as it was largely against classical
genetics and things of that nature,
which we now understand to be scientifically true.
As a result of this,
he lost his job with the department of for animal breeding at the Central
Research Laboratory and Moscow.
This did not face him.
However,
and despite Soviet persecution of Darwinism and modern genetic research,
he continued his work though in private Belia Yoav and other scientists of his
day is such as Lou media truth.
We're interested in subjects and questions of genetics such as how did humans
tame dogs.
These signs is sought to answer this question and in fact devise and experiment
and in fact replication of the process using foxes and operating under the
correct notion that animal behavior is influenced very much by genetics.
These scientists believe that if they began with a group of foxes,
about 30 male foxes and a hundred female Fox vixens as they're called and
selectively chose to breathe the foxes which were friendliness,
that over generations they would end up with a breed of Fox that was friendly
towards humans.
Accordingly,
they separated their foxes into three categories which persisted throughout the
experiment.
Category three consisted of foxes that were either scared of or aggressive
towards humans.
Category two were foxes who are not exactly aggressive or scared of humans,
but we're not really eager to interact with them,
and category one consisted of foxes who were friendlier towards humans
displaying friendliness and openness to socialization researchers.
We're careful not to train the foc as they had to let them develop naturally in
order to be sure that the change towards friendliness was genetic and not
environmental experiment as a scientist predicted actually had a considerable
degree of success and by the sixth generation,
the scientists had to add on a new class,
the iie or the domesticated elite class.
This group of foxes consisted of those who were essentially acting as modern
dogs do,
being eager to interact with humans,
having a general degree of friendliness,
enjoying socialization,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
This process,
while having a remarkable results,
seems pretty straightforward and in fact,
it kind of is so easy.
In fact,
a caveman could do it and they did it as soon as process that we ended up with
the modern dog and in fact,
many domestic animals today.
Today though with modern techniques,
they simply establish that behavior is largely genetic and selectively chose to
reproduce the organisms which display that kind of behavior.
And thankfully for the science,
his behavior with something which is easy to observe,
relatively easy to modify over generation.
So it wasn't as complex as a trying to breed six legged or flying fox cause
would be,
that may take a considerable amount of time doing it the old fashioned way.
Simple.
But what was going on with the Fox is biologically that was responsible for this
level and change of behavior.
Well,
quite simply the way the Fox has produced hormones changed,
but domestic foxes have lower levels of hormones like adrenaline than their wild
counterparts do.
And this actually has some physical effects on them as well.
For example,
the foxes for became spottier,
like many species of dogs and their estrous cycle changed in the 1990s however,
following the collapse of the Soviet Union,
the project suffered financially and the researchers were actually forced to
sell a number of the domesticated foxes going from 700 to 100 as of last report.
However,
the project is still running and is maintaining over 300 domesticated foxes.
And so that is the story of the domesticated Fox.
And perhaps one day if such projects take up again,
that'll be coming to a pet store near you.
In my opinion,
it's interesting to look into such studies and consider the possibilities of
what organisms could be changed and into what the wide diversity of life on
earth,
which are rose naturally including us,
tells us that there is quite a number of possibilities.
And when humans come to massive in an x,
it will be interesting to see what we do with such capabilities.
From what we do is like this and video is on many other subjects.
Be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.